[Music]
it's time to open the park Wonderland is
now open
I'd like it when the ideas come from you
that's what I'm talking about
operation look you look is it go honey
you see my cell phone where did your
model go I don't play that anymore
get back here
seriously
[Music]
No
welcome to the park have a nice day how
is this possible
hello my name is Steve I know who you
are you know who we are my mom and I
invented this place and somehow you came
to life
we're alive Wow
what happened here the darkness happened
it brought an army of chimpanzees but
sorry naughty it's time to bring the
park back to light
who's with me Oh with you oh no he's
allergic to voluntary
[Music]
such a woman those come-hither tusks Oh
[Music]
well that didn't work out at least we
got dinner
the Gigi
everything the light touches
is all kingdom
but Aki's time is ruler
rises and falls like the Sun
one day
the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember identity scan initiated
hello agent sterling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it worked
subject appears disoriented Walter what
did you do everywhere nobody notices
them it's the most perfect form of Spica
taste unburden me right now stop girl
seriously Hey look at me
look at you I can't not look at you
Walter I can see my butt and your face
at the same time
[Music]
you're probably wondering what's going
on just a minute ago I was with my
brother Charlie and now here we are
we're heading into dangerous territory
in this world nothing is what it seems I
need to find my little brother what just
need to face my gold that's not good
lucky for you I have contacts everywhere
ready to have some fun
[Applause]
lay man do it
[Music]
[Applause]
after me this was just garbage
[Music]
[Applause]
here he comes here he comes here he
comes here he comes Rico
welcome to Rimes City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah that didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and know
how to use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they try to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right you're adorable
they can't understand me kiss you no one
else here I don't need a Pokemon period
and what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
magic
gathering that magic is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
[Music]
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closing
Oh Jane its Jane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
[Music]
your life I don't get it will help me
rescue my friends go anywhere near the
sister system it's ruled by an alien
coin only the toughest you're gonna get
out of there alive I'm a queen whatever
I would not be I'm getting super evil
vibes here I could change my form to
something else if this makes you more
comfortable hey guys
he'll go back don't worst was much more
palatable double dots on your feet
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't
[Music]
welcome baby Dumbo all family here no
matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
yes something very rare
you have wonder
[Music]
you have mystique
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on an elephant's
wings
what's happening where they taking her
take Dumbo back inside but Jesus mom do
something she needs us
look at me we're gonna bring your mama
huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
your children need you to believe
you can do a jumbo shoulder
[Applause]
fight among
fly baby
[Music]
clothes and flows of angel
and ice cream
[Music]
means everywhere
subway
but now
we block
[Music]
so
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey somebody get in before he pokes an
eye out
[Music]
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens I
get real close right I'm like I don't
care which Cabbage Patch
you're from oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
you see the new movie trailer for what
you ain't see it see what what is it
duckie
but they're making another Toy Story
movie I thought those movies were gone
dog they made three movies did make
three movies this is number four toy
stories - yeah what about Buzz Lightyear
stuff I am Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger
what is like you to infinity and your
mom that's not right
you sure no that's not right I'm pretty
sure that's it let me show you to
insanity and what are you even saying -
immunity and response
hey guys
you got it all wrong it's to infinity
and beyond
[Music]